- We've had some incredible
times over the past five years,
Ooh!
- Ooh!
- Visited 14 countries.
- My God.
- Daddy, Daddy.
- No.
- [Jack] And we've loved every minute.
- Very much I enjoyed your company.
- Hug?
- No, I don't think so.
(dramatic music)
- Now finally.
Oh!
- Oh, my God!
- Daddy! (retching)
We're off on a magical mystery UK tour.
- [Michael] You need to
whack him with the oar.
- Michael!
Perhaps the greatest challenge of all.
It's delicious.
(beep)
Why, it's yummy.
- Sit up straight.
- It's very nice, sorry.
- So let's get this show on the road.
- Daddy!
(Jack thudding to ground)
Uh!
(discordant bagpipe music)
- Jack, just go.
- Oh!
- [Jack] I'm losing, my, oh!
- Completely mad, that boy is.
(melodic rock music)
(beep) was that?
- Sap, sap!
Shut that sphincter!
- Oh, what a good-looking man I am.
- (gasps) Look, Stonehenge.
- No, I am not-
- No, I want to see it.
- Shut that sunroof.
- I want to see Stonehenge.
- Come down.
- Oh!
Just 'cause you were there,
when they were erected.
- Very funny.
(soft melodic music)
- [Jack] Sad that it's coming to an end.
- [Michael] Yeah, I know I'm bloody lucky.
- [Jack] I'm bloody lucky as well.
- And we've had a great time
and I'm sure we'll do lots
of other things together,
just no more travels.
(melodic orchestral music)
- Do you feel nostalgic?
- No, I don't.
(melodic orchestral music)